[Musique]
les tirailleurs sénégalais éit une
fierté nationale les fer de lance de
notre armée coloniale avant que nombre
d'entre eux ne tombe dans l'oubli c'est
ce que nous rappelle ce documentaire les
derniers tirailleurs réalisés par Cédric
Condon avec vous venez de le voir les
émouvant témoignage recueilliis chez
certains de ces anciens soldats français
ces fameux tirailleurs sénégalais ne
sont-ils pas devenus les mauvaise
conscience de notre mémoire nationale
nous allons en débattre maintenant sur
ce plateau de débatoc en compag de mes
invités en commençant par vous etassek
bienvenue vous êtes conseillère
régionale de la région Île-de-France et
conseillère municipal à Bondi en sc
saint bien sûr là où ont été recueillis
les témoignages que nous avons vu dans
ce documentaire vous êtes la fondatrice
et présidente de l'Association pour la
mémoire et l'histoire des tirailleurs
sénégalais vous êtes aussi la petite
fille de l'un d'entre eux que vous
n'avez pas connu je crois mais qui a
combattu en Indochine en Indochine et
vous avez été à à l'origine de la
naturalisation de ces tir ailleurs CIT
en 2017 par François Hollande après le
film tirilleur on y reviendra tout à
l'heure il a eu une grande importance
hein ce film où auarcy tient le rôle
titre j'ajoute aussi que vous êtes l'une
des responsable de la Fondation pour la
mémoire de l'esclavage Éric dau est avec
nous bienvenue vous êtes cinéaste et
historien spécialiste de l'histoire et
des représentations sociales colonial et
militaire et puis également avec nous
Julie d'andurin bienvenue vous êtes
historienne professeur à l'Université de
Lorine à mes et votre dernier ouvrage
s'intitule un le général Gouro un destin
hors du commun de l'Afrique au Levant
publié aux éditions Périn et puis à
venir très bientôt je crois que ça sera
en en février prochain un livre qui sera
lui consacré aux troupes coloniales he
exactement chez le même éditeur non chez
passé composé bon ça sera donc à
découvrir chez passé composé quelques
nouvelles peut-être de ces anciens
tirailleurs que nous venons de voir dans
ce film abondit là où vous êtes
conseillère municipal que sont-ils
devenus ces tirailleurs qu'on a vu
témoigner dans ce film aujourd'hui ben
déjà on on a certains qui
malheureusement nous ont quitté euh le
documentaire a été tourné il y a 3 ans
maintenant et et en 3 ans
malheureusement certains nous ont quitté
donc c'est vrai que c'est très très
émouvant de revoir ces images euh de les
voir témoigner surtout dans les
différents combats eux aussi qu'ils ont
mené pour faire reconnaître leurs droits
et sinon les autres anciens sont rentrés
sont retournés dans leur pays d'origine
grâce à la mesure dérogatoire qui est
tombé en février 2023 euh ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que jusque jusque février
2023 les anciens tirailleeurs n'avaient
pas la possibilité de rentrer dans leur
pays d'origine ils percevaient ce qu'on
appelle une allocation minimum
vieillesse et ils avaient pour
obligation de rester 6 mois sur le
territoire français pour percevoir cette
allocation minimum vieillesse et grâce à
la mesure dérogatoire de d'Emmanuel
Macron qui est tombé en février ils ont
pu bénéficier de ce retour et la plupart
en tout cas de ceux qui sont dans le
documentaire sont rentrés le 28 avril
dernier au Sénégal donc ça a été un avec
ce minimum vieillesse c'est de l'ordre
de 950 c'est de l'ordre de 950 € par
mois oui donc une somme qui pourrait
sembler euh dérisoire pour certains mais
en tout cas une somme extrêmement
importante pour eux parce que c'est
grâce à cette allocation qu'ils peuvent
contribuer entre guillemets à la vie de
famille et notamment à leurs familles
qui sont restéses dans les pays
d'origine pant enfin revenir dans leur
pays d'origine tout à fait tout à fait
ce qui était extrêmement complexe c'est
que comme vous l'avez vu dans le
documentaire ces anciens vivaientent
seuls dans des foyers parfois exigus ou
dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles les chambres que nous avons
vu c'est 17 m² he effectivement des
conditions matérieles très très
difficile très difficile sachant
qu'avant ces chambresl il vivait déjà
dans 7 m²r on a on a mis tout un un
processus pour qu'il puisse avoir des
des des chambres décentes
aujourd'hui en fait quand ils vivaient
en tout cas seul ils envoyaient tous les
mois de l'argent à leurs famille hein
c'est c'est une réalité qu'on ne peut
pas nier cette mesure leur a permis de
rentrer après c'est encore complexe he
l'administration française est très très
complexe c'està-dire que la mesure
dérogatoire est tombée mais
l'administration ne suit pas encore
aujourd'hui euh on a juste un logiciel
français qui ne permet pas de verser
cette allocation sur des comptes
étrangers donc c'est encore compliqué
ils sont rentrés au mois d'avril on a
certains anciens qui n'ont toujours pas
touché leur allocation et ça ce sont des
combats qu'on doit entre autres hein
mais mais beaucoup hein à votre
association il reste combien de
tirailleurs sénégalais puisque c'est
encore le nom qu'on leur donne
aujourd'hui en France alors en France il
en reste moins de 40 euh le dernier
recensement qui a été fait suite à cette
mesure on a compté 35 37 ans ancien
ancien tirailleur africain sur les 37
pour l'instant 13 sont rentrés des enfin
en tout cas ont émis le souhait de
rentrer définitivement dans leur pays
d'origine certains doivent rentrer là
dans dans dans les jours qui viennent
d'autres souhaitent partir en fin
d'année mais il souhaitent surtout être
soulagé des démarches administratives
qui doivent être faites avant leur
départ et aujourd'hui ça reste encore
très compliqué donc on les accompagne du
mieux qu'on peut notamment avec l'ONAC
he l'Office national des anciens
combattants he qui s'est bien saisi du
dossier avec aussi la ministre des
Anciens combattants mais très clairement
et très concrètement les choses ne se
font pas si simplement mais aujourd'hui
il en reste environ un peu moins de 40
en tout cas dans le recensement qui a
été fait Éric dau les tirailleurs
sénégalais alors ça a été dit dans ce
film hein il a ce corps a gardé son
appellation il a été créé en
1857 sous Napoléon I par un certain
féerbe qui était alors préfet du du
Sénégal euh
néanmoins il a été constitué de de de
nombre de de de militaires issus
d'autres pays que le que le Sénégal hein
c'est dire qu'en fait ces tirailleurs
ont été recrutés parce que les les
pathologies tropicales qui frappaient
les soldats blancs étaient terriblees
donc il on pouvait pas pénétrer dans ces
pays sans utiliser une force locale et
au fur et à mesure de la conquête on a
créé des unités de tirailleurs soudanais
de tirailleurs àousa de tirilleurs
gabonais congolais et en 1900 on a
décidé de rationaliser l'administration
militaire a décidé de rationaliser un
petit peu tout ça et de tous les appeler
sénégalais en en hommage à l'origine au
premier bataillon de tirailleur qui
avait été créé à Saint-Louis du Sénégal
en 1857 alors ce qui a peut-être pas été
suffisamment dit dans ce documentaire
c'est que ces fameux tirailleurs
sénégalais ont participé à toutes les
phases de conquête coloniale en en
Afrique on parle des notamment
évidemment sous le le second Tempur mais
surtout sur la sous la 3e république et
puis aussi Madagascar le Maroc à la fin
du 19e siècle dans des conditions euh
qui ne sont pas décrites d'ailleurs dans
dans ce documentaire on est bien là sur
des phases de colonisation pour la
plupart assez violente ce sont à ces
phases de colonisation qu'on participé
également ces tirailleurs sénégalais oui
c'està dire que ça renvoie la complexité
des tirailleurs les tirailleurs sont
recrutés dans des parfois des
populations qui sont hostiles à d'autres
les Mossis contre les bambarans on joue
comme ça d'une population contre autre
il est clair que l'homme blanc tout seul
aurait pas pu conquérir cet immense
territoire euh que impérial et donc on
va effectivement s'appuyer avec des
promesses avec des primes ce qui fait
d'ailleurs que jusqu'à la Première
Guerre mondiale on n pas tellement de
problème de recrutement de tirailleurs
on les recrute assez facilement alors
justement à propos de ce recrutement
comment les recruteon ces tirailleurs
est-ce que c'est est-ce qu'ils sont
volontaire est-ce qu'ils sont
désignés par un responsable de tripu par
exemple je crois qu'il y avait quand
même des des des conscriptions
obligatoires alors il y a eu plusieurs
phases la première phase de la conquête
qui va grosso modo 1857 à 1914 euh il y
a il y a plusieurs systèmes on sait pas
très bien parce que qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que veut dire volontaire
lorsque vous venez recruter un jeune
africain au fin fond de son village la
notion est quand même assez assez floue
il est clair qu'il y a énormément de
volontaires jusqu'à la Grande Guerre il
il y a pas de problème de recrutement et
ce qu'on commence à faire c'est un
système de de détection chaque cercle
colonial au fur à mesure que
l'administration coloniale s'implante
chaque cercle va fournir des effectifs
théoriques et euh par exemple le cercle
de de kaola est réputé avoir 1000 jeunes
en âge de porter les armes et en
fonction des besoins l'administration
civile et militaire va en recruter bah
100 50 ou 1000 il est clair que quand la
grande guerre arrive là il y a un besoin
beaucoup plus important et qu'on va
passer à la constrption forcée en
particulier à partir de 1915 qui va
créer beaucoup beaucoup de problèmes en
Afrique entre de guerres on revient
puisqu'on a moins besoin de de tire
ailleurs on revient davantage à une
conscription plus ou moins volontaire et
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale je
crois que ce qui bien expliqué dans le
film là on a quand même AFF faire
pratiquement à un volontariat alors la
Grande Guerre bien entendu euh on va en
parler il éta il en était question dans
ce documentaire on va voir un premier
extrait du film concernant cette fameuse
guerre entre 1914 et
1918 en 1914 parce que la France manque
de soldats elle puise largement dans le
réservoir
africain 130000 tirailleurs sénégalais
viendront combattre dans les tranchées
les tirailleurs fascinent les Français
ils incarnent la force et la vitalité de
l'Empire les soldats Allemands eux
redoutent ces diables noir
183000 tirailleurs sont recruter en tout
à l'occasion de ce conflit sur sur 8
millions de Français au total hein
mobilisé ça permet aussi de de
relativiser un petit peu les les choses
mais le plan prévoyait d'en recruter
700000 semble-t-il du côté côté de de
l'armée française euh ce recrutement n'a
pas eu lieu il y a il y a des raisons à
ça oui il y a il y a effectivement des
raisons à un recrutement qui ne se fait
pas mais tout simplement parce que
d'abord les plans avaient été surévalués
c'est le le fameux projet de la force
noire de de Charles Mangin qui est
proposé à partir de 1910 mais qui existe
dans les dans les tiroirs en fait depuis
beaucoup plus longtemps en fait depuis
1904- 1905 et qui n'a pas de rapport
avec la Première Guerre mondiale
contrairement à ce que l'on dit souvent
hein c'est juste d'augmenter le nombre
de soldats et en quelque sorte de se
substituer à la conscription française
qui est en en perte de vitesse et donc
pendant la guerre euh on recrute
finalement moins parce qu'on s'aperçoit
déjà au Maroc en 1912 que au fond les
tirailleurs sénégalais sont très
sensibles au froid le maroc au maroc il
fait très froid l'hiver et que du coup
on peut pas les employer comme des
soldats blancs sur sur le sol français
et puis ensuite il il y a des problèmes
de de d'acheminement en fait des hommes
tout simplement qui coûtent cher à
l'armée et là c'est la raison pour Laco
il va y avoir un un nombre qui est
considérable 100 entre 130 et 180000
c'est considérable par rapport à
l'avant-guerre mais c'est comme vous
l'avez dit c'est peu au regard de la
mobilisation des Français qui est 8
millions donc 30000 d'entre eux
tomberont au combat entre 1914 et et et
1918 quels sont les principaux faits
d'armes de ces tirailleurs sénégalais à
l'occasion de ce ce premier conflit
mondial alors les principaux faits
d'armes alors il y a il y a quelques
faits d'armes naturellement sur le sur
le front là où on va masser les les les
troupes coloniales mais pendant la la
dès la première guerre mondiale et ça le
le le documentaire ne le dit pas
nécessairement dès la première guerre
mondiale les troupes noires ce qu'on
appelle les troupes noires sont assez
vite mélangées avec les troupes blanches
donc il y a pas particulièrement de
formation noire qui attaquent alors
maintenant si si si on cherche un petit
peu où est-ce qu'ils ont attaqué au fort
de douumont par exemple il y a le
souvenir des attaques de Sénégalais il y
a également le souvenir en en en 1916
1917 des des des Sénégalais des
débandades de Sénégalais devant les
mitraillux Allemands donc il y a à la
fois des faits d'armes et à la fois
aussi des souvenirs plus difficiles à
trouver pour les historiens de des
bandade et de
difficultés face à la guerre à la guerre
de masse telle qu'elle telle qu'elle se
fait en Europe Éric dou vous êtes
catégorique à cette question est-ce
qu'on peut dire que les troupes noires
ont servi de chair à canon sans
piternelle question et là vous êtes
catégorique et vous dites non ce myth
est faux ça n'a jamais été dans la
doctrine non d'une part je je crois que
Julie vient de l'expliquer c'était pas
du tout l'idée c'était pas de remplacer
les soldats français par des soldats
africains euh une des choses de Mangin
dans dans la force noire c'était aussi
de faire monter les troupe noir pour
occuper le Maghreb dont on était pas sûr
du tout on était en pleine conquête du
Maroc et de faire monter les unités de
l'armée d'Afrique à ne pas confondre
avec l'armée coloniale l'armée d'Afrique
c'est l'armée du Maghreb qui eux étaient
réputé grands combattants les
tirailleurs algériens les pays Algériens
de les faire monter sur le front
français donc l'idée c'était une
manœuvre en tiroir que le militaire
appelle une manœuvre en tiroir mais
effectivement autre chose importante la
plupart des unités ont combattu dans des
formation mixte c'est dire que très vite
on s'est aperçu que les tirailleurs tout
seul avaiit beaucoup de mal à avancer
qu' fallait les encadrer beaucoup les
encadrer les encadrer dans les
formations avec des soldats coloniaux
européens et au sein de grandes unités
mixtes donc att ce que vous dites parce
que le documentaire laisse penser que ce
n'est qu'à partir de la guerre d'Algérie
qu'on a eu affaire à des formations
mixtes absolument c'est c'est une des
choses qui qui que j'ai relevé dans le
documentaire il y a deux choses dont on
parle pas c'est cette mixité puis on
parle pas des cadres non plus les unités
de tirailleur é encadré jusqu'au grade
de capitaine souvent par des officiers
ou des sousofficiers africains assez peu
mais dans les dans les petits grades oui
et par des Blancs les les bataillons qui
participent à la à la reconquête de
douomon sont des bataillons mixtes donc
c'est c'est quand même important donc la
balle allemande elle va pas tout d'un
coup dans un groupe est précisément vers
le tirailleur plutôt que vers le cadre
blanc Cid par contre on peut quand même
parler du massacre de chasselet ou là
non mais chasselet c'est 40
ou mais ça c'est chasselet on va on va y
venir je crois c'est en 40 et du fait
des Allemands c'est c'est différent
c'est pas une volonté française de faire
de la chair à canon Chassel non non mais
c'est quand même 190 c'est un are
conflit auqu on bien entendur je pense
qu'il y a des choses qui sont
importantes à relever même si en
comparaison au nombre de soldats dit
français blancs parce que était
considéré comme étant des Français on
peut considérer que le nombre en tout
cas
d'engagés des troupes coloniales n'est
pas important au regard des pertes qu'on
a eu on peut considérer que si on était
aussi dans une situation coloniale et je
pense qu'il faut aussi pas remettre les
chos parler des pertes en 14 14 en 17
aussi 14 18 15 % sont tué 15 % des
effectifs de des tiraur de toute façon
même 1% c'est ça représente quand même
une perte important comparé aux pertes
de l'ensemble sont entre 20 et 25 %
voilà bah ils sont moins nombreux donc
c'est normal oui oui non mais c'est on a
besoin d'avoir quelques données comme ça
en tête he pour relativiser les chos je
crois je crois que c'est c'est moi je
partage votre avis c'est c'est pas un
débat ce qu' veut dire c'est c'est vrai
que de toute façon un soldat noir c'est
déjà trop mort mais simplement pour
faire attention au discours de la chair
à canon qui est globalisant et qui qui
donne ce sentiment que sans l'rique
France est envahie par l'Allemagne et
c'est un nouveau discours qu'on va
entendre en 4 en tout cas l'Afrique a
contribué à cette libération et c'est
important de le dire alors
1940 là
aussi dès le début du conflit hein on va
solliciter les les tirailleurs pour
qu'ils viennent se battre en métropole
cette fois ils sont combien et ils
jouent quel rôle alors c'est même avant
le conflit en fait dès dès 3839 la
France comprend qu'elle va aller vers la
guerre et les les hommes politiques et
militaires mobilise le le concept
d'Empire qui apparaît à ce moment-là
justement pour faire appel au troupes
coloniales et avec l'idée de rééditer ce
qui s'était passé lors de la première
guerre mondiale alors ce qui est
surprenant là ce sont les chiffres qui
sont donnés dans le documentaire c'est
que au fond entre la première et la
deuxème Guerre mondiale il y a pas un
différentiel très important en terme de
chiffres mais vous avez raison 179000
tirailleur mobilisés en 40 ils étaient
18 un peu plus de 180000 en 14 alors que
le le différentiel sur les les forces
globales entre la première et la deuxème
guerre mondiale sont de 1 à 10 donc on
voit bien que la la capacité de la
France à recruter dans son champ
coloniale n'est pas si fort que ça la
capacité n'est pas si forte et aussi
puissante lors de la deuxème Guerre
mondiale il y aurait des comparatifs à
faire des travaux de recherche pour des
jeunes historiens entre première et
deuxème guerre mondiale justement pour
évaluer comment se sont fait les
recrutements je reviens à cette capacité
de recrutement euh il y a aussi eu des
révoltes il y a eu des refus pour être
recruté euh oui les refus sont assez
bien documentés sur la Première Guerre
mondiale hein sur la la partie 1915-
1917 et il y a eu des révoltes qui ont
secoué véritablement hein le le les les
les territoires et que l'on a oublié par
la suite parce que quand blasdiag en
1918 a fait son recrutement donc
blasdiag je rappelle c'est un député du
Sénégal donc député noir qui part
recruter Blas lui-même fait oublier
parce que lui-même est noir et qu'il est
missionné par clémenceo fait oublier les
révoltes de 1915 à 1917 qui ont été
violentes et qui ont déstabilisé
certains territoires mais de fait le le
recrutement pendant la guerre est un
recrutement forcé dans certains
territoires et ça a donné lieu à des à
des paniques du côté du pouvoir colonial
oui bien sûr ou ça a été ça a été très
compliqué on a eu des témoignages
justement d'anciens tirailleurs de
bondit dont les parents enfin dont les
papas ont on participé à la Seconde
Guerre mondiale euh disait que Ben
souvent c'était des recrutements forcés
et qu'il y a eu des révoltes dans un
certain nombre de villages et qu'il
s'était préparé physiquement et
psychologiquement euh à ne pas être
recruté par par l'état français pour
pour pour le second et ça en fait c'est
c'est mal documenté parce que on a
uniquement que des témoignages de
descendant de mais c'est vrai que ça
mériterait de de faire des recherches
par des des chercheurs des historiens ou
de jeunes étudiants sur la manière en
tout cas dont le recrutement a été fait
pour la seconde guerre mondiale mais
bles Dian a eu de grosses difficultés à
convaincre en tout cas pour à recruter
en tout cas des soldats pour pour ce
deuxième conflit et il a fallu ben faire
un certain nombre de promesses notamment
sur la question des pensions et des
soldes qui seraiit plus
élevé il y a aussi un débat au sein de
l'administration coloniale elle-même van
volenoven qui est gouverneur de de
l'Afrique occidentale française et
contre la la conscription forcée il le
voit bien lui dit vous êtes en train de
priver l'Afrique de ses bras parce qu'il
faut pas non plus oublier la dimension
de l'effort économique qui est demandé à
l'Afrique est aussi très important dont
on parle pas beaucoup qui vaut aussi
avoir des répercussions extrêmement
importante donc c'est un vrai débat au
sein même de la société coloniale alors
il y a une période peut-être plus
compliquée pour ces tirailleurs
sénégalais c'est lorsqu'il a s'agit de
de soit de de mener des répressions
contre des soulèvements comme ça a été
le cas dans le
Constantinois en mai 1945 la répression
de Madagascar 1947 à la ils sont
associés et puis deux guerres
anticoloniales d'abord l'Indochine et
ensuite l'Algérie extrait du
documentaire l'égalité proclamée
n'empêche pas le commandement de
surveiller avec attention les 15000
soldats noir déployés en Algérie soit 5
% des soldats engagés dans ce conflit en
Indo-Chine il craignait la diffusion du
communisme la collusion avec le vietmin
la contamination de
l'anticolonialisme en Algérie c'est la
collusion religieuse qui est frraie
alors en indchine on craint du côté de
l'étatmajor français la contamination
par le communisme et puis en Algérie des
disensions autour des questions
religieuses hein la question
musulmane ça ça a été des des
guerres qui qui nous ont donné rendu une
autre image de ces fameux tirailleurs
sénégalais qui a détérioré peut-être
aussi leur image dans leur pays
d'origine qui allait avoir eux accès à
l'indépendance situation pas facile pour
les tirilleurs Sénégalais à ce Nive
alors sur la question des
représentations dans les territoire
africain on est encore pour le coup
assez mal documenté aujourd'hui sur ce
qu'on pensaient les populations locales
des tirailleurs il se dit que l'image
des tirailleurs s'est détérioré dans
l'entre de guerre mais on n pas de
témoignage
important quantité documenté et ça
pareil ça ça mériterait d'être travaillé
d'avant avantage quant à la
représentation sur la guerre
anticoloniale je crois que là c'est une
analyse d'aujourd'hui on sait que les
les les guerres d'Indochine d'Algérie
ont été des guerres anticoloniales mais
quand les les Sénégalais les tirailleurs
sont envoyés en Algérie en Indochine
d'abord puis ensuite en Algérie en fin
de compte ce sont des guerres coloniales
comme les précédentes c'est-à-dire
qu'ils participent au développement ou
au maintien là il s'agit du maintien de
du
territoire
colonial français de l'empire colonial
français et donc à ce moment-là il n'y a
pas nécessairement mauvaise conscience
la mauvaise conscience est venue après
coup hein c'est une construction
historique la mauvaise conscience et
elle est venue longtemps après et elle
est venue aussi du traitement ou de
l'absence de traitement sur les pensions
de ces tirailleurs
oui absolument il faut pas oublier que
dès 1895 les tirilleurs Sénégalais par
exemple participent à la conquettete de
Madagascar et qu'encore aujourd'hui
rapporte anecdote Madagascar car quand
un enfant est pas sage on lui dit on va
appeler les Sénégalais donc c'est resté
quand même dans certaines mémoires les
Sénégalais sont est réputé dans l'armée
coloniale comme des soldats extrêmement
sûrs on leur confie une mission il la
respecte à telle enseigne qu'un jour en
Indochine un général ayant oublié le mot
de passe se fait tirer dessus par un
tirailleur parce que il le connait pas
donc c'est c'est une anecdote mais ça
prouve la fidélité incroyable la
solidité de ces tirailleurs ils font la
guerre là on parle de ce qu'on a vu dans
ce documentaire on parle aussi de votre
grand-père qui a fait l'indochchine il y
avait des états d'ames néanmoins il y av
on a des témoignages vivant on a des
témoignages vivants qu'on peut
recueillir et puis les guerres de
conquête colonial en à partir de 1857 et
et ensuite la guerre d'Indochine et
d'Algérie le contexte était déjà
clairement différent pour avoir échangé
avec avec ces anciens tirailleur tous
ceux qui ont fait la guerre d'Algérie ne
souhaitaient pas y aller très clairement
ils ne souhaitaient pas aller en Algérie
et il y avait évidemment la question
religieuse il y avait aussi déjà la
fatigue d'avoir fait la guerre
d'Indochine ça a été extrêmement
compliqué pour pour eux et il y a aussi
la question de de de défendre en tout
cas ils étaient extrêmement patriotes et
euh et ils se sentaient il se
considéraent comme étant français mais
on commençait déjà à avoir un certain
nombre de de de révolte pour
l'indépendance de leur propre pays
d'origine donc aller en Algérie pour
maintenir ce pays en état de de de
colonisation c'était compliqué pour eux
la question religieuse a été clairement
une question pour eux trois d'entre eux
qui qui a pas reste dans le dans le
documentaire ne souhaitait pas y aller
il ne souhaitait pas aller en Algérie
deux d'entre eux ont été enfermés
pendant 15 jours et n'ont pas eu le
choix que d'y aller après donc cette
conscience elle était présente elle
était extrêmement forte et aujourd'hui
quand ils en parlent ils regrettent
amèrement d'avoir participé à ce conflit
mais ils arrivent en tout cas à à
l'expliquer il défendaient la patrie il
défendait la France et surtout il
n'avait pas le choix il n'avait pas le
choix ils avaient il s'étaient engagé
depuis un certain nombre d'années leur
famille comptaient sur eux sur la
question ben des pensions ils vivaient
enfin ils permettaient en tout cas à
leur famille de de pouvoir vivre
décemment et ils n'ont pas eu le choix
donc c'est c'est voilà là on a des
témoignages vivants 60000 tirailleurs
engagés en aguchine 20 % des effectifs
français et 15000 en Algérie 5 % cette
fois des effectifs qui ont combattu
durant cette guerre d'Algérie est-ce que
l'armée française avait suffisamment
pensé à l'après concernant ces tir
ailleurs sénégalais une fois que leur
pays d'origine en 1960 pour l'essentiel
ont effectivement rencontrer
l'indépendance et obtenu l'indépendance
alors je dirais que c'est pas son rôle
c'est pas son rôle de penser l'après
l'armée en général pense dans l'instant
ou dans dans l'après immédiat dans dans
elle est dans un raisonnement sur
l'emploi des hommes et ce qui va se
passer
après c'est pas c'est pas le rôle de
l'armée c'est le rôle du politique de
penser ce genre de choses quand est-ce
qu'on le dis tout ce corps des
tirailleurs alors la réflexion va
arriver à partir et ça le documentaire
le montre he la la réflexion commence à
arriver à partir de 58 oui voilà quand
il est question de la mise en place de
la communauté on commence à réfléchir au
sort des tirailleur et à ce que l'on va
faire d'eux et avec la question du
basculement dans les armées nationales
qui vont se construire le documentaire
montre assez bien cette transition ce
qui est bien montré aussi dans le
documentaire alors est-ce que ça a
marché ce basculement évoqué dans ce
docum doentaire on a formé des officiers
notamment à Fréjus c'est aussi dit dans
dans dans ce film est-ce que ce
basculement c'est le terme que vous avez
utilisé pour un retour dans les armées
des pays d'origine a fonctionné alors
pour le coup ce basculement a été assez
bien anticipé on le voit dans les
archives arriver assez tôt dans les dans
les documents d'archives parce que le le
monde politique et le monde militaire se
rend compte qu'on va aller vers les
indépendances et qu'il faut organiser la
prês et donc les fortom effectivement va
s'occuper de former les officiers et
pour les soldats les sous-officiers il y
a également des formations qui sont
prévues et les les tirailleurs eux-mêmes
sont assez demandeurs parce que c'est
une sacrée promotion sociale aussi pour
eux de basculer vers une armée qui est
une armée nationale où ils vont pouvoir
être chef eux-mêmes directement donc ça
c'est c'est un il y a des travaux on
commence à avoir quelques travaux très
intéressants sur cette sur ce momentlà
est-ce que pour autant ils sont
accueillis à bras ouverts dans leur pays
d'origine ou alors ils sont considéré
comme les anciens supposs des des des
coloniaux je crois que ça ça dépend
aussi des destins des pays à la Guinée
il sont le documentaire le montre
trèsinée 58 Guinée sont carrément
condamnés et certains vont vont mourir
d'ailleurs hein vont être tués d'autres
pays le Mali va très vite aussi basculer
dans un régime marxiste assez dur les
tirailleurs seront pas très bien vus
mais faut pas oublier que les fortomes
l'école de formation des officiers
ressortissant des territoires autreem
euh nous sommes un jour àusé faire le
calcul a fourni près de 14 chefs d'État
africains 14 chefs d'État africains pas
toujours dans les conditions les plus
démocratiques bien entendu mais en tout
cas donc ça a été un élément clé de la
la France Afrique bien sûr bien
évidemment évidemment très important ça
a formé non seulement les officiers
sortis de l'ffom mais aussi des
d'anciens tirailleurs le général etadema
était un ancien sergent d'Algérie bokasa
était un ancien capitaine d'infanterie
coloniale il y en a plusieurs donc il y
a il y a vraiment quand en Afrique on va
voir la une certaine faillite des des
des paires des indépendances qui dans
les années 65 70 vont cevoir les
populations l'armée va apparaître on
voit à peu près encore aujourd'hui le
même processus l'armée va apparaître
comme la structure organisée et ce sont
ces officiers qui vont prendre le
pouvoir ces derniers tirailleurs qu'on a
vu eux ils ont pas voulu revenir dans
leur pays
d'origine quelle a été leur situation
passer soldat français à
soldatcolis béninois non certains sont
restés sont restés soldats français très
peu par ailleurs d'autres ont intégré
les les les soldats enfin intégré en
tout cas l'armée de leur pays d'origine
euh et pour beaucoup certains sont enfin
son ils sont revenus parce que leur
situation financière était extrêmement
complexe extrêmement complexe bah déjà
il ne touchaiit pas la même pension
qu'un ancien combattant français donc ça
ça a été ça a été une des décisions qui
a été de de revenir en France euh et
ensuite ben les droits sociaux en France
ne sont pas forcément les mêmes que dans
les différents pays d'origine et leur
objectif à quand ils ne trouvaient pas
d'emploi stable quand ils n'ont pas pu
réintégrer comme il fallait l'armée des
pays d'origine ont fait le choix de
revenir en France après enfin moi par
exemple mon grand-père lui n'a pas n'a
pas souhaité intégrer intégrer enfin en
tout cas rester en France il a intégré
son l'armée l'armée sénégalaise il s'est
formé il était sapeur pompier et il
vivait très bien dans dans dans son pays
d'origine mais pour la plupart ça a été
extrêmement compliqué et c'est encore
compliqué aujourd'hui pour ceux de
d'Indochine et d'Algérie
notamment au Sénégal il en reste un peu
plus de 5000 il vivent dans des
conditions extrêmement complexes ça a
été extrêmement compliqué votre combat a
été extrêmement compliqué on en a parlé
au tout début de cette émission il y a
eu deux films qu'on fait avancer la
cause des
Tirailleurs Africains appelonsles comme
ça aussi hein parce qu'on a l'habitude
de parler de tirailleurs sénégalais mais
ce sont aussi ce qu'on peut appeler les
tirailleurs africain c'est d'abord
indigène de Rachid Bouchareb
2006 et ensuite tir ailleurs avec au
Marsille on l'a dit dans dans le rôle
titre en en en 2022 cette fois 23 2023
sorti le 4 janvier 2023 ou il a été
tourné en 2022 et sorti en 2023 c'est un
carton au cinéma c'est d'emblé plus d'un
million de vous dites ça fait 10 gagner
10 ans à la cause oui oui parce que
forcément le cinéma permet de
sensibiliser l'opinion publique et quand
on arrive à sensibiliser l'opinion
publique on arrive à toucher les
pouvoirs politiques euh donc forcément
un film comme indigène qui a permis la
décristallisation des pensions un film
comme tirilleur permet à nous acteurs
associatif d'avoir un élément un outil
pédagogique qui nous permet de
convaincre les pouvoirs politiques alors
en tout cas
l'Élysée a a préféré communiquer le jour
de la sortie du film sur cette mesure
dérogatoire en réalité on le savait
depuis quelques mois que cette mesure
allait tomber et euh mais très bien
c'est très bien c'est en tout cas ça
permet de sens is l'opinion publique
Jacques cherac François Hollande
Emmanuel Macron tout à fait TR
présidents de la répu du politique vous
disiez bon on a des domaines c'est assez
bien documenté d'autres pas encore assez
est-ce qu'on
collabore du côté français et africain
pour documenter cette histoire dont nous
venons de parler depuis maintenant un
peu plus de de 30 minutes alors du côté
africain pas tellement enfin quels que
soi les pays d'Afrique même le Sénégal
qui qui pourrait avoir les moyens d'un
point de vue archivistique de le faire
document assez peu mais la question des
pensions parce que personnellement je
pense que c'est la question centrale en
fait de la relation de la France à ses
anciens tirailleurs cette question est
extrêmement difficile à travailler moi
j'ai commencé à aborder le sujet sur la
Première Guerre mondiale l'issue de la
Première Guerre mondiale et la
distribution des pensions et on voit
bien que c'est ce que vous disiez sur la
bureaucratie française et sa complexité
que ça ça ne date pas d'aujourd'hui hein
ce problème et euh à la fin de la PR
prière guerre mondiale c'est très
difficile pour les les anciens
tirailleurs de recevoir leur porension
et je je tiens pour hypothèse mais c'est
une hypothèse de chercheur si vous
voulez qui qui mériterait d'être exploré
davantage que les pensions n'ont pas été
distribuées comme elles auraient dû
l'être en 1920- 1921 et que c'est
probablement à l'origine du drame de
tiaroy qui a lieu en4 1944 1944 parce
que tout près de Dakar hein voilà dans
la banlieu de Dakar avec un massacre
organisé par l'armée française alors
avec surtout l'exigence au départ des
tirailleurs d'être payés hein des
tirailleurs qui qui revenaient d'Europe
anciens prisonniers de guerre anciens
prisonniers de guerre et qui sont
envoyés au camp de tiaroy en attente
d'être envoyés dans leur famille et qui
et qui veulent qui veulent être payés
qui ne le sont pas et donc effectivement
il y a une mutinerie et qui donne lieu à
à un massacre 30 35 morts je crois et 3
c'est le chiffre officiel mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a un C d'horiens qui parle
euh de beaucoup plus voire même de
plusieurs centaines de morts à
l'occasion de de cet épisode que dont
vous venez de parler à l'instant c'est
la fin de cette émission je suis
vraiment désolé on passerait beaucoup
plus de temps avec vous c'est vrai pour
parler de ces ces fameux tirailleurs
sénégalais un grand merci à tous les
trois d'y avoir participé euh merci
aussi à selmaali qui m'a aidé à préparer
cette émission vos réactions ça sera
bien sûr sur hashtag Desbat dooc et puis
moi je vous donne rendez-vous pour un
prochain débat dooc et ça sera bien sûr
avec son documentaire et son débat à
très
[Musique]
bientôt